bitcoin ist aktuell auf dem höchsten
punkt jemals unter anderem bei tesla vor
kurzem bekannt gegeben hat die krippe
währung im wert von 1,5 milliarden us
dollar zu kaufen aber und jetzt kommt
das spannende bitcoins werden nicht
einfach so gedruckt wie euro oder dollar
sondern sie werden geschärft oder
gemeint und das kann einfach jeder
machen die einen laptop oder pc hat ich
hab noch absolut keinen plan wie das
mining funktioniert wahrscheinlich jetzt
nicht genauso wie bei minecraft aber es
ist offensichtlich extrem leicht da der
computer einfach die ganze aber es ist
sogar so einfach dass die grafikkarten
die dafür verwendet werden absolut
ausverkauft sind und man praktisch gar
kein dlc x30 90 30 80 und nicht mal mehr
20 80 mehr kriegt natürlich auch weil
jeder bitkom dem man dann damit
herstellt durch den aktuell extrem hohen
preis natürlich übertrieben viel wert
ist aber zum glück habe ich schon im pc
mit der grafikkarte herum stehen und
nicht vermutet ira und damit wenn ich
als frau so wie leicht das ganze ist und
ob es dann wirklich an macht jeder
machen kann ob ich dabei über den tisch
gezogen wird und vor allem wie viel
bitcoin bzw
euro pro tag ich damit erschaffen kann
bzw mein rechner weil ich das verstanden
habe fertig dabei nichts tun
ich habe so was noch nie gemacht ich
habe keinen plan was ich jetzt tun muss
ich werde einfach wie immer auf youtube
suchen aber ich find es trotzdem
interessant mal zu schauen wie lange
jetzt eigentlich dauert es ist alles
leute zum 1
der duo feiert gerade ein paar üble
halten bitcoin auf 2900 dollar
hochgeschossen ist ja mittlerweile ist
ganz einfach schon über zehn mal so wie
das auch schon bisschen probieren sie
das meinen jetzt aus ja ich habe so eine
extra geöffnet managers meiner use your
web browser cool also aber hier sie
können mit ihrem pc für stoller 60 pro
tag erzählen fürs nichtstun das wären
100 wird die euro im monat aber für uns
absolut gar nichts machen und jetzt was
das jetzt ok also ich weiß hat das
logischerweise die grafikkarte jetzt
nutzen sollte und in der tat die wir
jetzt beansprucht jetzt nicht mehr gras
bisher noch nichts verdient ich wollte
mal wie lange es dauert so hart ich habe
schon 0,00 19 cent also das war jetzt
schon mal mega einfach ich glaube nicht
dass es so leicht ist ich glaub ich
glaube ehrlich gesagt habe ich einmal
war das mal so lange ab bis dann dollar
steht und das wo ich mir mal das ganze
irgendwie wirklich auszahlen zu lassen
weil logischerweise nur weil eine zahl
jetzt steht heißt ja nicht dass ich das
geld schon hab cpu mining habe ich jetzt
auch mal aktiviert damit nur ein
bisschen schneller geht der prozessor
wieder zu 100 prozent ausgenutzt
die grafikkarte nicht gut ich das jetzt
einfach mal mein pc arbeiten warum nicht
[Musik]
also ich bin mir als ich ganz sicher
aber sie steht beantragen sie bitcoins
und beginnen sie mit dem mining in
echtzeit war das jetzt noch nicht echt
nice cash konto erstellen jetzt mining
für mein experiment werde ich diese
erstbesten software wohl blind vertrauen
aber das programm herzlich aktuell mit
die aktivierte firewall und virenschutz
natürlich die möglichkeit mit meinem pc
fast alles zu machen ja ja genau
englisch
ok jetzt hat man jeden schutzprogramm
schauen wir irgendwas gelöscht
wahrscheinlich sollte das nicht so sein
oder uns diese art von betrügerischen
software gibt es tatsächlich auch also
seid vorsichtig gut gekonnt ignoriert
start mining let's go hsk der benchmark
jetzt mehrere verschiedene algorithmen
und checkt an welcher für meine
spezielle grafikkarte dann am besten
funktioniert also besetztes decker
hashimoto mit abstand am besten aber
jetzt ist das mining ok und der garage
motor genommen weil der halter am besten
war bei mir ich bin gespannt wie viele
ich jetzt innerhalb von einem tag beim
nichtstun verdienen momentan habe ich
mir gerade gedacht wenn sie nicht gerade
etwas aufgefallen und zwar relativ
spannend ist hier bei diesem dienst den
er einst aktive anlagen das heißt man
kann aber noch mehrere sachen
zusammenschalten da ist mir auch
gefallen ich habe diesen guten laptop
klar der ist bestimmt nicht so effizient
wie mein pc aber besser als nichts
glaube ich oder das jetzt gerade mein
laptop ins drei dollar 45 pro tag so
jetzt laufen die 13 sogenannte aktive
anlagen das heißt pc ist mein pc mit
einer rtx 2080 mein laptop atx-20 60 und
der pc von meiner freundin den ich da
einfach mal geklaut hat bzw
ich lass das programm halt einfach im
hintergrund laufen und insgesamt sind es
jetzt aktuell 10 euro wo tags war von
aber auch schon bei 12 also ich bin mal
gespannt ich gehe jetzt ins bett und
dann sehen wir ob das überhaupt
durchläuft und natürlich vor allem ob
ich das geld überhaupt krieg 12 euro am
tag das wäre in dem monat 360 euro und
das hat einfach nichts tun und ich
glaube das klingt irgend ein bisschen zu
schön um wahr zu sein
die maschinen laufen als alle schon seit
ungefähr zwölf stunden ununterbrochen
durch ich bin jetzt praktisch panther
viele warum kam also mein pc ist ja
gerade auch drei dollar 30 cent gesunken
was natürlich viel weniger ist als die
fünf dollar 50 die wir gestern hatten
insgesamt meinen gesamtvermögen ist 0,00
0 0 93 30
bitcoin okay jetzt schon ausgezahlt
worden
also wir wurden jetzt bisher ein mal eur
7 cent einmal ein
30 und 1 x 1 26 gewesen ok alles
funktioniert ein bisschen weniger
geworden aber es funktioniert ausgezahlt
wird ja alle vier stunden
ich habe aktuell 359 bereits ausgezahlt
90 cent sind auf dem topf das heißt wir
haben jetzt bisher in ungefähr zwölf
stunden vier euro 50 fürs absolute
nichtstun gekriegt das nehme ich mit
die frage ist nur geld für das nächste
und klingt schön und gut aber irgendwas
muss ja passieren also mir beweisen kann
umsonst geld was genau passiert da
überhaupt und warum nennt als bitcoin
meinen also mein schiff zwar nicht
wirklich den ernst also wenn's mal aus
und dafür müssen wir versuchen zumindest
ein bisschen zu verstehen wie crypto
währungen also zum beispiel bitcoin
eigentlich funktioniert und das ist
jetzt zumindest mal mein versuch das
ganze etwas zu erklären wir könnten uns
mit kommen jetzt erst mal ungefähr so
vorstellen wie normales geld das man
sich einfach hin und her schicken kann
nur eben ausschließlich digital jedes
mal wenn eine person einer anderen
person mit contact wird diese
transaktion auf einer öffentlichen liste
festgehalten das macht die bank zum
beispiel auch ein kontoauszug ist ja
nichts anderes als eine liste von
zahlungs ein und ausgängen bei bitkom
kann jeder auf diese liste drauf
schreiben was er will damit jetzt aber
nicht einfach irgend jemand unbefugt
hingehen und sagen kann felix zahlt
thomas 10.000 euro muss jede transaktion
digital unterschrieben werden da wir
hier ja im digitalen raum sind könnte
man das jetzt theoretisch an kopieren
und einfügen aber damit das nicht geht
kommt jetzt kryptographie bzw
verschlüsselung nation man könnte auch
mathematische zwar bereiten die ich
jetzt nicht erklären werde
oder kann auf jeden fall kann jeder
hinterher ganz leicht überprüfen ob die
unterschriften echt ist ohne dass es ihr
gleichzeitig fälschen kann diese
transaktions liste ist aber jetzt nicht
an einem festen zentralen ort im
internet wie zum beispiel youtube videos
die er bei youtube sind oder eben geld
das bei einer bank ist sondern
theoretisch überall also dezentral und
jeder kann diese liste haben aus
verschiedenen gründen ist dieser liste
und das halt in blöcke oder blogs und da
kommt jetzt mit coal mining ins spiel
meiner sehen sich jetzt sozusagen im
virtuellen raum um nach transaktionen
die so rum schweren sammeln diese ein
und kombinieren sie zu einem block und
jetzt kommt's lösen mit viel rechenpower
durch zufalls kombination ein
mathematisches rätsel um diesen blog zu
verifizieren der erste der dieses rätsel
gelöst hat sendet das ergebnis an alle
welt und fügte einen blog zu blog chain
hinzu und bekommt für die
bereitgestellte rechenleistung von
bitcoin system eine belohnung einfach so
aus dem nichts gut geschrieben und das
habe ich jetzt eben hier auch gemacht
einfach mal einen pc bzw
meine grafikkarte zufällig irgendwelche
zahlen kombinationen durch raten zu
lassen um eben mit zahlreichen anderen
leuten die genau das gleiche machen
diese rätsel zu lösen jedes mal wenn das
bitcoin system ebenso eine belohnung
ausgeschüttet wird wirklich bitcoin aus
dem nichts erschaffen und so werden
bitcoin geschürft oder eben gemeint
einfach als anreiz dafür dass man die
transaktion also die zahlungen von
anderen leuten aus führt das war ultra
simple kehrt und ich habe auch alles
einmal so hackstock kriegst wenn ihr
euch dafür interessiert dann guckt euch
dafür ein video in der beschreibung an
dass ich mir auch angeschaut hat und aus
dem ich meine informationen für das
system ist ultra genial deswegen auch
das video aber auch 30 minuten was
natürlich hier den rahmen sprengen wird
und zack hiermit sind unsere 24 stunden
beendet und haben in dieser zeit sieben
euro 30 erfand er meint lag ungefähr so
im angepriesenen bereich ich sehe gerade
kaum noch 78 cent dazu also haben wir
insgesamt acht euro und 18 fürs
nichtstun
das sind immerhin 242 euro für ist
absolut nichts und jeden monat da kommt
nicht mehr richtig ordentlich sozusagen
eine frage ist jetzt wie komme ich
überhaupt an das geld heran trägt das
überhaupt privat ist jetzt komplett die
abzock masche und ja und ich habe jetzt
irgendwie mal wo man direkt mehr zur
verfügung gestellt aber bevor wir das
herausfinden ist noch eine spezielle
sache spannend wir jetzt acht euro 18
bedient aber wie hoch sind eigentlich
die stromkosten bestehen und werde mich
hier dieses gerät das handy benutzt habe
ich gehe davon aus das ist einfach
zwischen meinem pc unter steckdose
stecken kann und dann herausfinden wie
viele kilowattstunden ist man zwar baut
ja also das richtigen kabel hierbei
waren kabelmanagement zu finden können
sich als schwierig herausstellen als
erwartet wie viel strom verbraucht du
110 watt braucht mein pc im quasi
leerlauf über 24 stunden hinweg und bei
einem für deutschland durchschnittlichen
strompreis von 32 cent pro
kilowattstunde sind wir noch insgesamt
bei 84 cent hast echt schon vieles wird
mit seele läuft ja auch einige fassen
kann also auch wenn ich hier nicht mit
ein sondern einfach nur weil ich habe
den ganzen tag arbeitet richtig spannend
wird jetzt aber zu sehen wie viel der pc
braucht wenn ich das bitcoin mining
beziehungsweise die grafikkarte komplett
auslasten einigen staaten jetzt
obschon hh er schießt schon ordentlich
nach oben
dabei braucht er als alle 250 watt was
aus gehirn auf 1 eur 92 am tag kommt
wählt das ist natürlich jetzt nur für
diesen einen pc deswegen dürfen
natürlich auch mal den erlös von diesem
einen pc verrechnen und das waren hier
360 - 192 sind ein euro 74 den wir also
effektiv am tag profit gemacht haben im
monat das 52 eur 20 das ist eigentlich
auch nicht schlecht oder halt 110 euro
wenn man einfach den strom gar nicht
selber zahlen muss sondern dass die
eltern machen aber dass man sich auch
ein bisschen viel für ein pc
wie komme ich jetzt meine kohle bistro
klingt jetzt gar nicht so kompliziert
ist aber alles 110 weiß account das
passt folgte erst mit zwei faktor
authentifizierung aktivieren macht auch
aus sicherheitsgründen wenn man zwei
faktor vegetation zum ersten markt wird
ist es für 24 stunden erst mal geblockt
dass ich geld zu holen zwei faktor
authentifizierung ist am start wir
machen mal bistro jetzt kann ich hier
auch genau mit quality etwas ja kann man
ein bitcoin with the dress einstellen
die adresse habe ich erstmal hier am
handy kopiert wenn man in so genannten
bitkom wolle dass ich mit
vorinstallierter eine app die adwords
jetzt hier ein bitcoin etwas nehmen was
bedeutet etwas nehme auch er einen namen
geben das kann man machen was man will
okay okay jetzt in ihrem traktor codia
okay naja ok haben maximal noch nicht
ich muss noch ungefähr fünfmal so viel
ich habe 0,00
02 ich brauche aber 0.00 ein bitcoin
okay das heißt ich werde noch fünf
weitere tage meines bevor ich dann mein
geld kommen und zusätzlich ist es
erstmal gelockt man nach der zwei faktor
authentifizierung interessent erst mal
einen tag lang gesperrt was ist mein
vater dazu hat sich das ganze gelohnt
und kriege ich die auszahlung also ich
denke als allererstes dass die
auszahlung kommen wird wenn ihr wissen
möchten ob das geld ankommt dann habe
ich für euch ein video auf einem kanal
verlegt wo ich noch mal ein kleines
update zu machen an und für sich findet
tatsächlich hat sich das schon gelohnt
also ich konnte das wirklich nebenbei an
bord so laufen lassen ohne dass mein pc
jetzt nennenswert schlechter ist weil
die grafikkarte nutzt man wenn man nicht
gerade wirklich aktiv zockt als normale
endverbraucher fast nicht mit ungefähr
50 euro profit mit meinem pc zumindest
ist ultra stark fürs nichtstun mein
laptop auf der anderen seite der aktuell
ungefähr 800 euro wert ist würde im
monat auch immer noch 30 euro profit
schaffen was immer noch starkes und je
nachdem wie der bitcoins natürlich
steigt lohnt sich das ganze noch viel
mehr und wenn er fällt dann natürlich
weniger ich hatte ursprünglich die
bedenken dass das ganze eigentlich
unnötig ist und dass deswegen der strom
den man dafür verbraucht auch community
die stromverschwendung ist also ich mich
aber mit der thematik auseinandergesetzt
habe und da solltet ihr auch habe ich
herausgefunden dass das echt ein ultra
ultra praktisches ding ist mit extrem
vielen wichtigen anwendungsmöglichkeiten
die allerdings erst natürlich den rahmen
von diesem video springen will
ich würde also sagen dass das für die
meisten leute wahrscheinlich die
effizienteste art und weise sein könnte
geld zu verdienen
die ich auf diesem kanal jemals getestet
habe neben online umfragen online pokern
fall war ist es glaube ich für die
breite masse vielleicht sogar am
sinnvollsten vor allem bei man und auch
wirklich nichts dafür tun
ob das geld wirklich rum kommen sie
darauf ein zweiter kanal link ist eine
wieder beschreibung uns damit
verabschiede ich mich auch schon für
heute ich mache jede woche eines dieser
experimente also wenn ihr das nicht
verpassen möchte abonniert gern diesen
kanal und ansehen muss man erst mal
wieder alles gut
[Musik]